hey everybody welcome back the planet
coaster just a short introduction in
this video I'll be working on a German
restaurant blueprints with a beer garden
in front of it and it's not the most
interesting thing that I've ever tried
but the main reason that I wanted to try
it is to experiment a little bit with
the Christmas decorations I haven't
really been able to find some time to
work with them yet and I didn't want to
directly do something related to the
Christmas theme instead I think they're
very flexible unusable in so many
different ways that I wanted to build
something which kind of shows off the
different ways in which you can actually
use these Christmas decorations to make
anything a bit more cosy and I think the
German theme is an especially good theme
to try that with since it kind of flirts
a little bit with the general idea of a
Christmas theme it's cozy and it's got
like this sort of Mountain Alpine vibe
to it
without being directly Christmassy and
so that's a pretty good reason why I
wanted to try this myself but it's not
actually the main reason that I'm making
this video actually the main reason that
I'm making this video is to bring some
attention to a live stream that the
frontier developers have organized in
which the community managers add phones
here a tempo are gonna be doing a
24-hour live stream for charity the
charity in this case is special effects
which raises money to help people that
are disabled actually play video games
as well and for the live streams Bo will
be doing 24 hours of planet coaster and
at will be doing 24 hours of elite
dangerous and of course in this case I'm
mostly concerned with a planet coaster
myself and so what they'll be doing is
actually have guests throughout these
different streams there will be guests
from the planet coaster team themselves
but there will also be guests from the
community and one of these guests is
gonna be me and basically i along with
the lady's honor and Rudy Ren Kimmel are
making a park with blueprints to be
auctioned for the stream because they're
trying to raise as much money as they
can of course and one of the ways that
you can help them raise money is a
doughnuts I'll put a link in the
description to it and also a link in the
description to the original forum thread
in which you can find some more
information but people could also bid on
different kinds of items so those are
the different ways in which they're
actually helping to raise money for
charity here and a we figured it would
be a lot of fun to show off the game and
at the same time be able to have
something for people to bid on and
that's what we're working on at this
point
so basically until now when I'm working
on my thing
Rudy Ren Camille has made the park
entrance and the lady's honor has made a
tropical blueprints and it was basically
up to me to finish it off with another
blueprint for which I wanted to work on
this German thing which is actually
quite a challenge for me since as you
might know I am pretty bad at keeping
the scenery amount low within certain
buildings but I had to keep it under
2,000 for this one so uhm it was a bit
of a challenge in that respect as well
but anyway if you want to check out the
stream itself also post a link to that
in the description and something to keep
in mind is that by the time that this
video is uploaded the stream should
already be on its way for a few hours
but I won't be there yet I will be there
with Rudy Ren Kamel and the ladies Einar
adds around 6 p.m. GMT which I believe
is 7 for all of the mainland Europe
people and is around 2 p.m. I think for
the East Coast so that's when we will be
there showing off some parts showing off
blueprints and videos and talking a bit
about the game so I hope to see you guys
there and I hope you guys also donate to
the charity but if you don't it's all
fine anyway because of course part of
the cause also teachers to have
everybody of the community come together
and well celebrate the game without
sounding too cliche I hope anyway I'm
gonna go back to what I'm building here
for a little bit of a split second well
known exactly split second but um here's
more or less the basic shape of the
building I got that down pretty quickly
and most of the work here actually goes
into all of the detailing and one of my
favorite pieces because so far I've used
just mostly pieces that were already
in the game at this point the new roof
pieces though are super flexible and
usable if you wanna make like custom
roofs which is sort of did with the hip
roof on the front their only problem is
that it took me a pretty long amount of
time but I really love those pieces but
they're the biggest sort of changed for
me here has been all of the different
gingerbread pieces and also the icicles
and different snow pieces because all of
those pieces are recoverable and have
also two very small different shapes
which we didn't have before and I think
for that reason they're actually
extremely flexible and you can make some
amazing stuff with it so I actually just
used some of the gingerbread decorations
to make like some painted on decorations
which you sometimes see and these kind
of alpine and German houses but they're
also super useful for ironworks which
I'll get to later on in this video or
decorations on top of roofs there's a
lot of stuff that I'm gonna get back to
in that respect I just had to add a lot
of the planks over here because
obviously the most important detail
around the walls of a building like this
is really getting the wooden framework
right and I don't know in this case I
sort of just went with whatever I felt
like usually my approach to making these
things is making sure that I know where
my windows are gonna be then have the
horizontal bars sort of on top and the
bottom and the middle of the windows go
in the vertical beams on the size of the
windows and then fill in all the spaces
that are very open and look like they
still need to be filled in with more
wood with either crosses or just
diagonal beams and that's basically my
quick strategy for getting the wooden
beams in and generally what I've been
doing for a long time and usually works
get some nice decorations in also I
wanted to get a few Christmas
decorations in here just to add a bit of
green stuff to the building which just
makes it look a bit more charming but my
one of my favorite things here actually
has been the new Christmas decorations
because as you might know I'm a huge fan
of adding very small pieces to roofs
like golden balls and Peaks to make them
look a little bit more fancy and so far
we didn't
have many pieces to try that with it
always took a lot of experimentation
with all kinds of different pieces that
we have in game to get something that
looks just about right but now with the
new Christmas decorations that are
recoverable I think you can do a lot
more than just hang them in trees and
make Christmas trees out of them so one
of the things that I wanted to try over
here is actually use them on the top of
roofs to make these roof decorations and
that's something which I really love so
far and it's something where I think
there is a very bright future for these
kinds of objects and I'm looking forward
to trying and placing them a bit more in
the future I haven't really been able to
do so much at this point and just very
quickly tried some stuff before I went
into this building but that aside I
haven't really trended much but I think
if you just sort of open your mind to
the different kinds of things that you
can do you might be able to use icicles
to make roof decorations or use
gingerbread pieces to make Gables and
gates for roofs and there are so many
different things that you can do with
these pieces it's I am pretty stoked
actually which sounds pretty weird
because they're super small pieces but I
think when it comes to detailing these
are gonna be game changers at least in
some different things like this one and
of course there's the smaller things
like these decorations and the lights
that you can add around buildings which
is also just one of those small touches
it's not something like structural that
really changes a building but it's
something that just makes them look that
little bit more cozy look that little
bit more like it's actually alive and I
think it's it's such as like that that
makes the new update so useful for me I
do like the snow theme but it doesn't
feel like something that substantially
changes the way that things look in the
game but I think that does go for some
of the new objects which we now have
speaking of which by the way just as a
very quick sight notes I've seen quite a
few people request that I make a
Christmas special series I'm not
actually sure about that and the main
reason that I'm not too sure about it is
that actually have more than enough
series running at this point with Favara
City skylines as well as kind of Kali
Beach and planet coaster college but I
might try it see
if I can do something like me all new
we're in about three days I can make
something small and Christmas special
but don't expect me to do anything
because I'm not sure if I have enough
time and resources actually do that
within this short notice but it's
something that I would maybe like to try
it because so far I haven't really tried
and work with the Christmas theme yet
whereas that sort of what everyone is
doing at this point it's just that I am
mostly stoked about the new objects in
general because I think whenever you get
new objects in a game like this the
amount of things that you can do just
sort of exponentially increases please
there are many more new combinations
that you can make with every single new
object that's entered into the game
which sounds super nerdy I know it's
this Wharram
usually most into when it comes to this
kind of stuff and it just kind of makes
the the game in general possible to be
that little bit more realistic anyway at
this point the the building is almost
finished I wanted to put the small beer
carton sort of area in front of it since
this is a blueprint it's a little bit
confined to one area I didn't want to
make it like very fluid flexible and
path based since obviously it all has to
fit in 2,000 pieces and it has to be
something that you can just plop down in
a park and leave it at that
so I wanted to make the other sort of
terrorists out of the wood in front of
the building itself out of these straits
wooden roof pieces and that's pretty
much how it's all built and I'll build a
small Terrace with some tables chairs so
that we actually have a small beer
garden in full of it but that's
basically just its I want to keep it
quite well usable in different kinds of
cases or wherever you could fit it
inside a park so here I'm just finishing
off the details on the small plaza in
front of it like I said I wouldn't
really usually make this so square
because one of the things that just
makes it look much more interesting too
is to have a much more fluid sort of
area around it with many more curves and
interesting shapes when it comes to
paths but this is just what is more or
less the easiest kind of thing when I
had to make everything out of scenery
and make sure that it fits when you're
placing it as a blueprint so also the
table
and shares had to be quite simple since
the entire thing has the common in one
blueprint so it's just a couple of
blanks for the tables actually a bunch
of stuff for the chairs though because I
didn't want to end up making chairs that
are just super derpy so there were quite
a few like different very small wooden
cornice pieces in there but there's not
too many tables and chairs so I'm not so
worried about that and on the other side
I just wanted to play some general
simple scenery so a small board as if
you're actually entering a restaurant
right there some barrels and general
scenery and some planters wherever I
could because you do often see these
beer gardens with having like trees
between the tables and being just sort
of underneath the treetops I just wanted
to be careful with that since that sort
of blocks out the view of the building
itself and finally this is one of my
favorite things and this is definitely
my favorite way to use these pieces I
haven't really seen it before but they
are perfect for making ironworks like
putting them together in all sorts of
different directions in ways you can
make some beautiful cast iron pieces so
that's something that I wanted to try
here for the little sign in front of it
and I took the golden Peaks to decorate
that a little bit anyway that wraps it
up for this video
thank you guys for watching I hope to
see you guys maybe tonight in the
livestream but anyhow thank you for
watching and I hope to see you guys
later
[Music]